hello and welcome to this video this is
just a short video to point out
what i think i mentioned in one of the
blitz game videos
that um i think more or less all of my
repertoires and courses on chessable are
on sale
but not for very long anymore and i just
wanted to point that out so if you want
to get any of my courses
and i'm just going through this we have
the
the lifetime repertoire number goes in
that i did together with daniel bearish
full repertoire for black against d4 the
latest one the dirty harry sicilian that
you also
saw on the channel in some games fight
like magnus is on sale
they keep it simple ones and so on
they're all on sale
but not for long anymore this is why i
wanted to make that short video so
if you always wanted to get one of those
this is a good time now
so if you see currently it's just like a
little bit
more than a day left so you could get it
today
like upload it on august 30
or tomorrow this is um the time frame
also i wanted to point out that for the
dirty harry let's
go on to that this is also like one day
left one day and 15 hours
and i link that in the description of
the video
there is a peek inside video here on the
channel uh sorry on on
chessable where i'm talking a little bit
about the course
how it came about you can i can start
the video here
yep so i'm going to link to that i
thought about making a video for my
channel
also about the dirty harry like like a
preview
but it it's already there so just
linking to that one on the chessable
side is a good one
um as well so make sure to check um this
sale out it's just um
one day and a couple of hours left so if
you wanted to get one of those
now is a good time to do so alright
thanks for watching this video
and have a look at the dirty harry peek
inside video
if you are interested in this funky new
sicilian line
thanks for watching